let's get more should we uh in the form
of uh the labor party the opposition
Johnson Reynolds Shadow Secretary of
State for business energy and Industrial
strategy that's a mouthful isn't it on
your business card uh my goodness me um
your leader must have had quite
um an enjoyable weekend
well
clearly we've seen a lot of our
political opponents have continued to
have a difficult time but I would say in
politics you make your own look and
you've got to be in a position to
benefit from your opponent's weakness
where they've made mistakes like this
and I think that's what we can say in
the labor party that we've done on Boris
Johnson I think people will be watching
this just saying when is this soap opera
going to stop you know I think the
conservative party as a whole need some
time to sort itself out it would be much
better doing that in opposition rather
than what can cause any damage to the
country going forward but these kind of
claims if people if you claim people are
forcing you out you don't then go and
resign that makes no sense whatsoever
um will you vote for him to be suspended
well I have to see the report
I mean this is this is the whole joke
and he's resigned claims well you know
this claim was a kangaroo conservative
majority on that committee conservative
majority in Parliament to vote on it if
you are found guilty the recall petition
is actually like an election you've got
up to ten thousand of your constituents
vote for it then you've got a
by-election in which you can stand so he
had everything going babe I honestly
believe Boris Johnson doesn't know what
the truth is I think he doesn't know
when he's lying and that's often what's
got him into trouble in his life in
Korea but we'll have to see the report
and see what it says you'll be eyeing up
all three of the seats after the
resignations over the weekend eyeing up
all three of those constituencies not
necessarily going to win them are you
well we're definitely going to contest
them very strongly you're right to say
these are not going to step down and
look at the lip dance certainly not
we're in second place in these seats we
are the Challenger we are the
alternative to the conservative
government that's the case that we'll be
putting forward you're right to say will
take nothing for granted I mean these
are seats we've not traditionally held
so we'll have to work very hard put our
case forward for that but I think
particularly our message on the economy
on the cost of living on getting this
country back on its feet restoring some
pride and self-respect and removing this
soap opera of a government I think
that's a compelling case in every part
of the country
um what about Nicholas sturgeon
well I was not going to comment on on
the specifics but I think what we've
seen should she step down or should she
be suspended uh while there's an ongoing
legal uh inquiry well the police
investigation should obviously be there
to run its course and not be interfered
with in any way but I would simply say
with the SNP there dissent from a few
years ago where frankly they looked
all-powerful is clearly what's going to
get the attention they're recording
government in Scotland is awful as well
and I think I've been Scotland quite a
lot of last week people do want an
alternative they do want to change and I
will put the case to anyone in Scotland
that change should come from a change in
the UK government to a labor government
and not from Independence and I am very
very confident making that case okay but
should she step down
I I'm not going to comment on what she
should do I think the police
investigation should run its course well
I I understand she's been released
without charge at this stage I'm not
asking you to comment on the court case
I'm asking whether she should be
suspended
while that is or the the legal case
while that is continuing should she be
suspended or should she say you know
what I'm just going to step back from
being an I'm a speaker now look I
her treatment as a former first Minister
I think should be the same as any other
back bench or a member of the Scottish
Parliament I understand whether it was
an investigation of this kind they don't
usually resign or suspend them from the
Scottish parliament in this way and said
there was a privilegious process similar
to what we've been talking about in
relation to Boris Johnson in the House
of Commons but I think the the soap
opera itself detracts from the fact that
people do want to change in Scotland and
I think the change that we're putting
forward is what we can sell so labor
doesn't think she should be suspended
well I I I'm not going to comment on the
specifics of it I haven't seen the
charges that have been brought against
her I don't know
I don't know the case with that so I I
simply would say that is for the
Scottish Parliament to deal with as it
usually would and I think the political
case for us to make is the change in the
future of Scotland which will come from
a UK labor government you must be
thrilled though at what's happening in
Scotland at the moment as far as
politics is concerned even though you
are significantly behind the SNP still
well look I have always believed that
the best feature for Scotland is within
in the UK and I think the way to make
people more people convinced of that
case is to show them what a UK labor
government could do in terms of
industrial policy getting the economy
growing again sorting out Public
Services respecting the Devolution that
exists and those some of those key areas
but working with Scotland in order to
give them the future they deserve and I
think we can do that we are of course
excited that the poor show labor coming
back and winning in a significant number
of seats potentially in Scotland because
usually what people want to know are
general election in England they want to
know what kind of Labor win in Scotland
because that's crucial to forming a
majority and in Scotland they want to
know can labor win in England and we can
surf the local elections and the polls
that we've seen the answer to both those
questions is yes talk to me about the 28
billion pounds that you promised to
spend on green projects
um are you still planning to spend that
I was looking at something like 28
billion pounds a year until 2030. now it
would appear that you've rode back on
that and said 28 billion pounds a year
after 2027. no it's a welcome
clarification the bottom line is this
labor is still committed to the kind of
active industrial policy that will
deliver Net Zero and generate good jobs
in all parts of the country public
investment to leverage in a much greater
amount of private investment has always
been key to that so it's planning reform
so it's changes to business rates to how
the apprenticeship Levy works so you've
got the skills and supply chain to do
that it was always the case it's not
like a tap where you can just turn on 28
billion pounds the projects we've looked
at to allocate that to are things like
home Energy Efficiency green steel
getting the gigafactories our Automotive
sector needs and some of those will have
to be built up over time but it's also
important that we can say that I've
always believed economic transformation
and sound money are not in contest with
each other you've got to have both now
Liz trusses government horrible as it
was for the British people anyone with a
mortgage did prove that very very
clearly so we're putting our Ambitions
and our policies in the context of the
overall economic policy that we will run
I think that Clarity is welcome because
more and more people are clearly looking
at the polls and thinking there could be
a labor government we want to know the
details okay so what was the
misunderstanding then because Rachel
Reeves said 28 billion pounds a year to
spend on green projects look 28 billion
pounds a year is broadly the level of
investment that is projected to be
required
let me explain the figure though it is
the figure required for the kind of
economic transformation that is
necessary to hit net zero that's what
you said you would invest we are talking
about now though yes but what people
want to know are you going to keep that
figure in review in relation to how
quickly you can deliver those projects
to the well but now we've put the
clarity on it as required because there
has been a substantial change and I
think particularly the cost of servicing
the UK is debt following the Liz trust
government brief as it was you've got to
put your Ambitions in the context of how
you would it was only an ambition well
that is the level of investment we want
to get up to what we're talking about
now is how we will deliver well I think
the labor party is saying very clearly
we recognize to turn around the fact
that UK has the lowest business
investment in the G7 we've got to
replicate what some other countries have
done leverage in that private investment
spend some more money the figure
required is the figure required to do
the the overall transformation that was
the right thing to say we're talking
about how we're going to deliver it in
the here and now in the in the financial
environment that we're in and the fiscal
envelope that will inherit so you might
change some of your other figures as
well then well no but I would always say
that the Lord star has to be is a
commitment to fiscal discipline to our
fiscal rules of making sure we can
deliver what we're about that's what
people people always know we've got good
Ambitions in the late part we've got
good intentions for public services they
want to know are we going to be able to
deliver that are we going to recognize
the conditions that we're facing that is
all that we've clarified this weekend
but the big story is still it's a big
Divine lump in ourselves in the
conservative party because if you want
the kind of industrial policy that will
give a future for the automotive sector
the steel sector will deliver good jobs
in all parts of the country you're only
going to get that from labor you're not
going to get that from the conservative
party because they simply don't believe
in it well they might say something
different I'm sure they will next time
they're on Jonathan Reynolds always a
pleasure thank you very much indeed
thank you